bref un passé les bords d'un si ça se
trouve elle est partie hier à calavi a
pas de mobile une intime conviction
d'antoine rimbaud un film qui raconte la
quête de l'innocence dans une des
affaires les plus mystérieuses la sphère
ligue i en février 2000 suzanne viguier
disparue très vite son mari jacques
viguier est suspecté écoutez plutôt le
ton de cette journaliste
le 27 février dans cette maison quelque
chose a basculé car les détails sont
troublants jacques viguier a mis une
semaine pour déposer plainte et surtout
le matelas sur lequel dormait sa femme a
disparu et si le ton et si suspicieux
c'est que les enquêteurs ne vise que le
mari même s'il ne cessera de clamer son
innocence
aucune autre piste ne sera vraiment
envisagé mars 2000 jacques viguier et
placé en détention provisoire
son avocat de l'époque proteste
personnes neuf mois plus tard il est
libéré
mais les enquêteurs n'en démordent pas
c'est lui le coupable
le message des enquêteurs semble clair
la piste jacques viguier n'est pas
abandonné la recherche du cadavre de sa
femme continue plus que jamais les
rumeurs courent et deux clans
s'affrontent ceux qui le pense innocent
comme ses enfants et d'autres dont les
soeurs et l'amant de suzanne qui le
pensent coupable en 2002 près de deux
ans après les faits jacques viguier
professeur de droit public s'exprime
face caméra afin de mettre fin aux
rumeurs je ne sais pas d'où est sorti un
homme band sur selon laquelle j'aurais
fait une conférence sur le crime parfait
alors comme vous entendez
naissance comme ça c'est absurde ça n'a
jamais eu lieu et je ne sais pas d'où
ces calomnies peuvent venir
les années passent aucun corps n'est
retrouvé et le climat de suspicion
autour de jacques viguier est pesant en
2003 un écrivain publie une
contre-enquête et dénonce un acharnement
médiatico-judiciaire dont l'opinion est
que cette enquête a été ouverte mais la
montée c'est à des fonds non inscrits
dans un couloir en 2009
neuf ans après les faits s'ouvre le
procès un procès sans corps sans preuve
et sans mobile
jacques viguier est acquitté mais le
procureur général fait appel nouveau
procès un an après jacques viguier et
deux nouveaux a quitté la fin d'un
acharnement pour son avocat eric dupond
moretti
plus personne ne pourra sous-entendre
plus personne ne pourra suggérer la
culpabilité de jacques viguier
je voudrais simplement vous dire que la
cour d'assises du tarn n'a pas manqué ce
soir son rendez-vous avec la justice
dix neuf ans après les faits le corps de
suzanne viguier n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé l' affaire n'est toujours pas
résolue
[Musique]